This is the new president
and vice president of the Philippines
during a YouTube Q&A months
before their landslide election victory.
Ferdinand Marcos Jr., known as "Bongbong,"
shares the same name as his father,
the notorious autocrat who led
a military government in the Philippines,
which tortured
and killed thousands of citizens
while he and his family
stole billions from the public purse.
But none of that stopped Bongbong
Marcos winning this year's election.
The people have
spoken. They have given Marcos
a resounding victory.
Marcos won by a landslide.
He got almost 59% of the votes.
This was an epic win.
The days after the election
friends and colleagues
from pretty much everywhere asked me,
"How could this happen?"
Using the power of social media,
Marcos, his election team
and supporters have rewritten history,
claiming his father's
era was a time of prosperity and strength
rather than murder
and theft on an industrial scale.
It's frustrating for us
because all this time we have been
debunking the disinformation,
the lies that helped him win
this election.
Please subscribe to us.
While Marcos's
opponents contend online misinformation
played a key role in his victory
there's no way to prove it.
Meanwhile, Marcos himself has repeatedly
denied his campaign engaged in or had
any connection to social media posts
with false or misleading claims.
I guess for the journalists
and fact checkers in other countries
where this could possibly happen as
well, I wish you good luck.
When the iPhone was
released in 2007, just under
6% of the Philippines was on the web.
But smartphones changed that.
Now, two-thirds of the country's
110 million
citizens are connected
and spend 10 hours a day online.
That's more than any other country.
You can just imagine how much time
we spend here on social media.
Even here,  walking on the street, you can see people
looking down on their phones,
not looking on the road.
And then according to the data,
we use social media to gather information,
including the news,
and at the same time to connect to people.
So it's really our main source
of information here in the Philippines.
Filipinos spend more than four hours
a day on social media, with Facebook
being the most popular platform
with nearly 84 million users in 2022.
A survey here recently
showed that more than half of the people
who said that they're using social media
as their news source
find it very difficult
to distinguish between what's true
and what's false on social media.
So you can just imagine
the extent of the problem.
The 2018 Cambridge Analytica scandal
saw the data mining
firm questioned over its work
for Donald Trump's presidential campaign.
One whistle-blower described
how questionable rule of law,
high social media usage and corruption
made the Philippines the perfect place
to test the limits of online manipulation.
Bongbong Marcos has been building
his online presence for over a decade.
During his unsuccessful 2016
run for vice president
he relied heavily on online
messaging.
For his 2022 campaign
he sidestepped traditional media,
instead speaking directly to voters online
in short video blogs.
He gets a lot of engagements for that
and a lot of people like that about him,
the vlog thing, they really patronized
that because I guess it humanizes him.
I've seen analysis on social media saying
that he intentionally did not attend
debates and interviews because that was
what contributed to his loss in 2016.
So there was
a revisiting of
the strategy, the campaign strategy, and
as we are able to see now, we could say
that it has been effective.
Bongbong has over 7 million followers on
Facebook and another 2 million on YouTube.
His supporters flood news feeds
and message boards with election messages.
But political posts
and videos are often disguised.
A lot of the disinformation
that's spreading on social media,
especially in the lead up to
the elections, comes in the form of news.
Some are quoting personalities
inaccurately, but are presented
in such a way that they look like
and even imitate
the colors of mainstream media.
While VeraFiles,
other news organizations and Marcos's
opponents cite dozens of instances
of what they call disinformation,
the term itself can be problematic.
In the context of political campaigns
messaging regularly relies on exaggeration
and half truths, often labeled as spin.
Inside this gray area, social
media has thrived as a powerful tool
for politicians everywhere.
In the well over 600 posts
fact checked by VeraFiles,
a large majority attacked Marcos's rival.
While positive misinformation was skewed
the other way.
And a huge number of that actually benefited
Bongbong Marcos
in the way that it hyped up
his presidential campaign
and it also tried to distort
historical facts
regarding his family.
In the 1970s, Ferdinand
Marcos had led a military government
of uncommon brutality.
He disbanded Congress, silenced the media
and used the army to torture
and kill thousands of citizens.
Through all of this, Marcos
and his wife, Imelda, became
exceedingly wealthy
by siphoning money from state funds.
All the while, the Philippines
economy crashed and many people suffered.
A critical part of Bongbong Marcos's
election campaign
was convincing millions of people
these things simply didn't happen.
Despite the brickbats, the criticism,
the pure hate
that has been heaped
upon him over the last 30-plus years,
his memory,
his legacy continues to endure.
The Ferdinand Marcos era is portrayed
by his supporters as one of prosperity,
despite economic downturn.
Thousands of citizens labeled enemies
of the state were killed and tortured.
Extravagant parties
on the presidential yacht...
And discussions
about the billions of dollars stolen
are met with blanket denials.
Ferdinand Jr. is the man
in the flashing bow tie.
Social media helped spread this message,
with Marcos Jr. claiming
he was presenting
his own version of history.
The love for the Marcoses never really left here
in the Philippines.
Even after they were ousted,
they maintained
quite a strong bailiwick
in the northern Philippines.
And that's
where the most loyal supporters are.
It's possible Marcos would have won
even if social media wasn't part
of the equation.
His huge margin of victory could owe more
to alliances with local leaders,
endorsements by parties
affiliated with former presidents
and loyalty to his family
among the political elite
and everyday citizens.
It's hard to determine
whether online disinformation played
a critical role in Marcos
becoming president.
And it's even harder
to connect it to its sources,
let alone anyone directing the effort.
When I talked to people and asked them
who they were inclined to support,
if they said Bongbong Marcos
I would say why?
And there would be this gauzy look
and these sentiments expressed like,
you know, his father was a great man,
he was a strong leader,
Philippines needs strong leadership now.
And you would say, OK, well,
what about this?
What about that?
What about the other thing?
And they would blow it off.
The response would tend to be
one of two things.
They would say, "oh, look,
I was a kid then, or I wasn't born then,
it's nothing to me."
Or they say it's fake news.
Tonight, a brutal dictator's son
winning the presidential election in the
Philippines by a landslide.
Bongbong Marcos has been elected
as the next president of the Philippines.
And I think that's a very
telling indication as to how successful
this disinformation campaign
benefiting him is.
God bless the Philippines.
God bless our work.
The days after the election,
friends and colleagues asked me,
"how could this happen?"
Then I began to wonder
whether the more pertinent question was
what was actually going to stop it?
You have supporters, real people,
and then on the other hand,
you have fake accounts.
And these fake accounts, plus
the real people who are spreading this,
that creates an ecosystem
wherein this disinformation spreads.
We're able to monitor and flag
these online disinformation content,
but we really cannot pinpoint
who is the person or the persons
but one thing I can tell you
is President Bongbong Marcos,
he likes to disassociate himself
and his team from this information
campaign that largely benefited him.
In fact, he even said that he's
actually the victim of "fake news."
Some people say that
history was revised online.
What do you, what is your response to that?
Show me.
Show me where this revisionism
on our part, from our side,
whatever you want, show me.
Anything that we have said
we can prove.
How much of a concern is disinformation
to this administration?
If any illegal acts have been committed
then proper venue for
that would be the courts.
But no such wrongdoing has been committed.
Another major factor in Marcos's landslide
victory
was the effect of his running mate,
Sara Duterte, daughter of the previous
president, Rodrigo Duterte, who remains
popular in parts of the Philippines.
This time around, with Sara Duterte
running by his side,
he was able to win those provinces
in the southern
part of the country where the Dutertes hail from.
And he was able to double
the number of provinces that he was able
to win compared to his 2016
vice presidential race, which he lost.
It's really a consolidation
of two powerful
political dynasties, political families.
One hailing from the north,
that's Marcos, and the other hailing
from the south, and that's Duterte.
The Philippines
excels at dynastic politics.
The two presidents prior to leader Rodrigo
Duterte, they were children of presidents.
The lower house of our Congress,
we have majority
and most of our lawmakers are products
of political dynasties.
There's even a belief
that the good traits,
the leadership qualities of a father or
a parent
is passed down to his or her child.
So that's
how much political dynasties are welcomed
and elected here in the Philippines.
While Marcos and Duterte
ran on a ticket of national unity,
online their supporters pushed lies and attacked
the opposition candidate, Leni Robredo.
She was accused of having an affair
while her daughters
were accused of sex scandals,
all of it unsubstantiated.
A lot of these Facebook pages
and Facebook groups
that we were able to flag spreading
disinformation and misinformation,
some of them carry his name
in their account names.
And we actually also observed back in 2021
that a lot of YouTube videos
that are misinforming people,
what happens is
the video was uploaded on YouTube and
then there are a number of Facebook pages
that reuploads it on Facebook
that also reuploads it on TikTok
and this suggests that there is automation
or that only one person administers
or moderates these accounts.
And so it also suggests that there is
an organized effort
or campaign with regards
spreading mis-and-disinformation.
My father built more and better
roads, produced more rice
than all administrations before his.
So will it be with his son.
You will get no excuses from me.
Now as President, Bongbong
Marcos fashions himself
as a pragmatist,
focused on quality-of-life issues.
On foreign policy, he's promised to
grow closer relations with China
even as the two countries clash over
fishing rights in the South China Sea.
All the while
maintaining historic links to the USA.
This idea or this feeling or this,
shall we say, opinion
I have of my father, of the man, has just
been strengthened as time goes on.
What's also noteworthy is Bongbong
never talked about martial law
in a negative light.
It's all about admiration for his father,
a promise to continue
the good projects
that came out of that era.
The facts of the past is not really
as effective as the facts of the present
and the future.
Maybe it's because the people
now cannot relate with what ever happened
during the martial law of Marcos Sr.,
and they actually only care
about what's going to happen to them now
and what's going to happen in the future.
And Marcos Jr. apparently was able
to present himself effectively as someone
who will bring about positive change,
who will bring hope,
and who will unify the country towards
a better tomorrow or a better future.
If you're going to get a platform
like social media
that reaches a lot of people,
you're going to create a way
by which this version of history
is going to spread, and your supporters
are going to spread and believe it.
Imelda Marcos famously said in
one of the documentaries about her
Our job as fact checkers, and not only fact
checkers, but as journalists,
as amplifiers of truth, would be
more challenging in the next six years.
We're preparing for it,
and hopefully we could go through it
without any problem.